- [Instructor] If I were to ask you,
what is five
minus three plus two?
What would you say that is?
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
All right, well if you
wanted to tackle this,
you would really just read
it from left to right,
or you would compute
it from left to right.
You'd first figure out
what five minus three is,
and five minus three is equal to two.
And so you'd say, okay,
that's going to be two
plus two, which of course
we know is equal to four.
Now, what if I were to
involve a little bit
of multiplication or division?
If I were to go up to
you and I were to say,
what is five
plus three times two?
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
Well, you might be tempted
to do it in a similar way.
You might be tempted to say,
okay, I'll just go from left to right.
I'll first compute what five plus three is
and that of course,
would be equal to eight,
and then I would multiply eight times two
to get 16.
But it turns out that this
would not be the right
way to approach this,
because for very good reasons
that we'll study in perhaps future videos,
we don't always go left to right,
especially when we're dealing
with different types of operations.
And the standard way
that this is approached
is that multiplication
and division will be done
before addition and subtraction.
So the way that you would
actually compute this
is that you would compute
the three times two first.
So you would say that
this is the same thing
as five plus six,
five plus six, which is going
to be equal to 11, not 16.
So this is going to be equal to 11.
So with that out of the way,
let's do a few more examples.
Let's say someone were
to approach you and say,
what is nine
minus six divided by three?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, as I just said, we would
do multiplication or division
before we do subtraction.
So we'll actually do the
six divided by three first,
and six divided by three is two.
So this simplifies to nine minus two,
which is equal to seven,
and I really wanna emphasize,
it's important that you get this idea
that multiplication and
division should be done
before the addition or subtraction,
unless you're given some
other types of directions.
Because if you just
went left to right here,
you would have said
nine minus six is three,
and then you would've
divided that by three,
which would have given you one,
which is clearly a
different number than seven.
Let's do one more example, just for kicks.
Let's say that someone were to ask you,
what is two
times three minus one?
Pause the video and try
to figure that one out.
Well, in this one, doing
our multiplication first
is also the same as going
left to right first.
So if we do two times three first,
two times three is six,
so that's six,
and then we would wanna
calculate six minus one,
which is of course equal to five.
So big picture, if you
just have a bunch of things
that are being added, subtracted,
multiply, and divided,
and there is no parenthesis in it,
you would always prioritize
the multiplication
or the division over the
addition or the subtraction.